This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. If you grew up speaking a language other than English, you probably reached for words in your native tongue without even thinking about it. Coachley, it's Werksa, Mal de Porco. Alma Palma. There are phrases in every language that are deeply evocative and often untranslatable.
这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是香卡·维丹塔姆。如果你在成长过程中说的是英语以外的语言，你很可能会不经意地脱口而出母语中的词汇。比如口语里的“Coachley”、“Werksa”、“Mal de Porco”、“Alma Palma”。每种语言中都有一些极具画面感且常常无法翻译的短语。
If you're studying a new language, you might discover these phrases not in your textbooks, but when you're hanging out with friends. My name is Jennifer Diakone Cruz. Jennifer moved to Japan for graduate school. And I ended up living there for 10 years. It took just one week of living in Japan for Jennifer to pick up an important new term. Mendo Kusai.
如果你正在学习一门新语言，你可能不是在教科书里发现这些短语的，而是在和朋友闲逛时学到的。我叫珍妮弗·迪亚科内·克鲁斯。珍妮弗曾搬到日本读研究生。“我最后在那里生活了 10 年。”珍妮弗只在日本生活了一个星期，就学会了一个重要的新词：面倒臭い（Mendo Kusai）。
Here's what she says it means. It's this phrase that describes something between, I can't be bothered or I don't want to do it or I recognize the incredible effort that goes into something even though it shouldn't be so much of an effort. Still don't have a clear picture? Imagine this. It's a Sunday afternoon and it's raining outside and you're at home and you're pajamas all nice and cuddly and and you're at home in your pajamas all nice and cuddly and maybe you're watching Netflix or something and you suddenly get a craving for potato chips and you realize that you have none in the kitchen and there's nothing else you really want to eat and maybe the
以下是她对这个词意思的解释：这个短语表达了一种介于“我懒得理会”和“我不想做这件事”之间的感觉，或者说我意识到了完成某件事所需的巨大努力，尽管它本不应该需要费这么大劲。脑海里还是没有清晰的画面？想象一下这个场景：一个周日下午，外面下着雨，你待在家里，穿着舒适暖和的睡衣，也许正在看网飞或别的什么节目，然后你突然很想吃薯片，接着你发现厨房里一包也没有了，而也没有其他你想吃的东西了，也许那家
convenience store the shop is really not that far away maybe it's even less than a hundred meters away but you just can't bring yourself to even throw your coat on over your pajamas and put your boots on and go outside and walk those hundred meters because somehow it breaks the coziness and it's just too much of an effort and you can't be bothered to do it even though it's such a small thing. So it's Mendok's eye. The moment she heard it, Jennifer realized Mendecksei was incredibly useful. It describes this feeling so perfectly in such a wonderfully packaged encapsulated way, and you can just, it rolls off the tongue and you can just throw it out, ah, Mendecksei, I just don't want to do it.
便利店、小商店其实离得很远，也许甚至不到一百米，但你就是无法让自己在睡衣外面套上一件外套，穿上靴子，走到外面去走那一百米，因为不知怎么的，这打破了那种温馨感，而且实在太费劲了，你懒得去费那个神，哪怕这是一件这么小的事。这就是“面倒臭い”（Mendok's eye）。珍妮弗一听到这个词，就意识到它极其有用。它以一种美妙打包、高度浓缩的方式完美地描绘了这种感觉，而且它读起来朗朗上口，你随口就能说出来：啊，真麻烦（Mendok's eye），我就是不想做。
If you're bilingual or you're learning a new language, you get what Jennifer experienced. The joy of discovering a phrase that helps you perfectly encapsulate a feeling or an experience. The phrase brings an entire world with it, its context, its flavor, its culture. Today, we explore the many facets of this idea. Languages are not just tools to describe the world, they are ways of seeing the world. The categorization that language provides to you becomes real, becomes psychologically real. This week on Hidden Brain,
如果你是双语者，或者正在学习一门新语言，你就会懂珍妮弗的经历。那种发现一个能完美概括某种感觉或经历的短语的喜悦。这个短语带来了一个广阔的世界，包括它的语境、它的韵味、它的文化。今天，我们探讨这个观点的许多不同层面。语言不仅是描述世界的工具，它们也是看待世界的方式。语言为你提供的分类变得真实，在心理上变得真实。本周的《隐藏的大脑》，
they're in half the, they're back in the world. That's right. How the languages we speak shape the way we think, and why the words we use are always in flux. My guess today is, why don't I let her introduce herself? The way to say my name properly in Russian is Caleria Ramannovna Boraditskaya. So I don't make people say that.
它们回到了半个世界中。没错。我们说的语言如何塑造我们的思维方式，以及为什么我们使用的词汇总是在不断变化。我今天的嘉宾是——为什么不让她自己作自我介绍呢？用俄语正确说出我的名字的方法是卡莱里娅·拉马罗夫娜·博拉迪茨卡娅。所以我通常不让人们念这个名字。
Well, that's kind of your name. In the English-speaking world, she goes by Lera Borditsky. Lera is a cognitive science professor at the University of California, San Diego. Long before she began researching languages as a professor, foreign languages loom large in her life. When she was 12, her family came to the United States from the Soviet Union. My family is Jewish and we left as refugees. I decided it was very important for me to learn English because I had always been a very verbal kid and I'd always always the person who recited poems in front of the school and led assemblies and things like that. And to arrive in a new
好吧，这算是你的名字。在英语世界里，她被称为勒拉·博里茨基。勒拉是加州大学圣迭戈分校的认知科学教授。在她开始以教授身份研究语言的很久以前，外语就在她的生活中占据了重要地位。在她 12 岁时，她的家庭从苏联来到美国。“我的家庭是犹太人，我们作为难民离开。我决定学好英语对我来说非常重要，因为我一直是个很健谈的孩子，我一直是那个在学校里背诵诗歌、主持集会之类活动的人。来到一个新
place where you can't tell a joke and can't express an idea, oh, it's just really painful because you feel like your whole self is hiding inside and no one can see it. And so I set myself the goal that I would learn English in a year, and I wouldn't speak Russian to anyone for that whole first year, and I did that. Lera now tries to understand languages spoken all over the world.
地方，你却无法开玩笑，无法表达一个观点，哦，这真的很痛苦，因为你会觉得你整个真实的自我都藏在里面，没有人能看到它。所以我给自己定下一个目标，我要在一年内学会英语，而且在头一整年里不和任何人说俄语，而我真的做到了。”勒拉现在试图理解世界各地人们所说的语言。
She once visited an Aboriginal community in Northern Australia and found the language they spoke forced her mind to work in new ways. Just saying hello was difficult. I had this wonderful opportunity to work with my colleague, Alice Gabi, in this community called Pumperau in Uncapurek. And what's cool about languages, like the languages spoken in Pumperau, is that they don't use words like left and right. And instead, everything is placed in cardinal directions,
她曾访问过澳大利亚北部的一个原住民社区，并发现他们所说的语言迫使她的思维以新的方式运作。仅仅打招呼就很困难。“我有幸与我的同事爱丽丝·加比一起，在乌卡普雷克一个名为潘佩劳的社区工作。像潘佩劳说的那样，这些语言很酷的一点在于，它们不使用诸如‘左’和‘右’这样的词。相反，一切都是根据方位方向来定位的，
like North-South-Eastern West. So the way you say hi in Cooke-Tire is to say, which way are you heading? And the answer should be North-North East in the far distance. How about you? So, quite literally, to get past hello, you have to know which way you're heading. And, in fact, speakers of languages like this have been shown to orient extremely well, much better than we used to think humans could.
比如东、南、西、北。所以在库克泰尔语中打招呼的方式是说：你要去哪儿？回答应该是：去往远处的西北偏北。你呢？所以，字面意思上，要想打完招呼，你必须知道自己正朝哪个方向走。事实上，事实证明，说这类语言的人方向感极好，比我们以往认为的人类所能达到的水平要好得多。”
We always knew that certain species of animals had abilities to orient extremely well, much better than we used to think humans could. We always knew that certain species of animals had abilities to orient that we thought were better than human, and we always had some biological excuse for why we couldn't do it. We'd say, oh, well, we don't have magnets in our beaks or in our scales or whatever. But it turns out humans can stay oriented really, really well, provided that their language and culture requires them to keep track of this information. I understand that if you're in a picnic with someone from this community and you notice an ant climbing up
我们一直知道某些动物物种具有极佳的定向能力，比我们以往认为的人类所能达到的水平要好得多。我们一直知道某些动物物种具有我们认为比人类更强的定向能力，并且我们总是为为什么我们做不到这一点找一些生物学借口。我们会说，哦，好吧，我们的喙里或鳞片里没有磁铁之类的。但事实证明，只要语言和文化要求人类记录这些信息，他们就能保持非常好、非常好的方向感。我听说如果你和这个社区的人去野餐，你注意到有一只蚂蚁正往
someone's left leg, it wouldn't make a lot of sense to tell that person, look, there's an ant on your left leg. Well, there may not be a word for left to refer to a left leg in a lot of languages there isn't. So, you might say there's an ant on your northwest leg. The fun example I give my students is imagine playing the hokey bokey in a language like this.
某人的左腿上爬，对那个人说“看，你的左腿上有一只蚂蚁”，这在逻辑上就说不通了。嗯，在很多语言中，可能根本没有“左”这个词来指代左腿。所以，你可能会说西北腿上有一只蚂蚁。我给学生举的有趣的例子是，想象一下用这样的语言玩“抖鸡巴舞（Hokey Pokey）”。
You know, there's no left leg or right leg. As soon as you move the leg, it becomes a different leg. So you may start with moving your southwest leg in but then you have to move your northeast leg out. So I find that I'm often directionally and navigationaly challenged when I'm driving around that I often get my east west mixed up with my left right for reasons I have never been able to fathom. So but if I understand correctly I would be completely at sea if I visited this Aboriginal community in Australia because I have often absolutely no idea where I am or where I'm
你知道，没有左腿或右腿之分。你一移动那条腿，它就变成了另一条腿。所以你可能先迈进你的西南腿，然后你必须迈出你的东北腿。所以我发现自己在开车时经常方向感和导航能力不佳，我经常把东西南北和左右搞混，原因我一直没法弄明白。不过，如果我没理解错的话，如果我访问澳大利亚这个原住民社区，我会完全迷失方向，因为我经常完全不知道自己在哪里，或者要去哪里。
going. Well, you would be at sea at first but actually it's something that's not so hard to learn. Many people have this intuition that, oh, I could never learn that. I could never survive in a community like this. But actually, that's exactly how people in those communities come to stay oriented is that they learn it, right? You have to do it in order to fit into the culture and to speak the language. I had this cool experience when I was there. I was trying to stay oriented because people were treating me like I was pretty stupid for not being oriented and that hurt.
嗯，一开始你确实会不知所措，但实际上，这并不是很难学会。许多人有一种直觉，哦，我永远学不会这个。我永远无法在这样的社区里生存。但实际上，那些社区的人正是通过这种方式保持方向感的——他们学会了，对吧？你必须这样做才能融入文化并说这种语言。我在那里时有过这样一次有趣的经历。我试图保持方向感，因为人们认为我连方向都辨别不清，显得我很蠢，这让我很受伤。
So I was trying to keep track of which was which. And one day I was walking along and I was just staring at the ground. And all of a sudden I noticed that there was a new window that had popped up in my mind. And it was like a little bird's eye view of the landscape that I was walking through and I was a little red dot that was moving across the landscape. And then when I turned this little window stayed locked on the landscape, but it turned in my mind's eye. And as soon as I saw that happen, I thought, oh, this makes it so much easier.
所以我试着弄清楚哪个是哪个。有一天我走着走着，一直盯着地面。突然我注意到我的脑海里弹出一个新窗口。这就像是我正在走过的风景的一个微型鸟瞰图，而我是沿着风景移动的一个小红点。然后当我转身时，这个小窗口锁定在风景上，但在我的心眼（脑海）中它旋转了。我一看到这个发生，心想：哦，这下简单多了。
Now I can stay oriented, and I kind of sheepishly confess this to someone there. I said, you know, this weird thing happened. I saw this bird's eye view, and I was this little red dot. And they said, well, of course. How else would you do it? Of course that's right. What was remarkable for me was that my brain figured out
现在我可以保持方向感了，我有点羞怯地向那里的某个人坦白了这件事。我说，你知道，发生了这么一件奇怪的事。我看到了这个鸟瞰图，而我是这个小红点。他们说，废话。你还能怎么做？当然是这样。对我来说最了不起的是，我的大脑在尝试了一周后，想出了一个解决这个问题的绝佳方案，对吧？所以我觉得只要你有想这么做的理由，这其实是人类很容易学会的事情。时间是另一个概念，它也是我们看待和描述世界的核心。你做过一些实验，探讨不同语言中对时间的截然不同概念如何塑造我们对世界的看法，以及我们对故事的理解。
a really good solution to the problem after a week of trying, right? So I think it's something that is quite easy for humans to learn if you just have a reason to want to do it. Time is another concept that is also central to the way we see and describe the world. And you've conducted experiments that explore how different conceptions of time in different languages shape the way we think about the world and shape the way we think about stories.
经过一周的尝试，这确实是一个非常好的解决方案，对吧？所以我觉得，只要你有想做的理由，人类要学会这其实是相当容易的。时间是另一个概念，它也是我们看待和描述世界方式的核心。你曾做过实验，探讨不同语言中对时间的各种概念如何塑造我们对世界的思考方式以及我们对故事的构思方式。
How so? One thing that we've noticed is this idea of time, of course, is very highly constructed, but our by-minds and our brains. So you can't see time, you can't touch time, you can't smell or taste time. But it is a completely crucial part of the human experience. Of course, you also can't experience anything outside of time. It is the very fabric, the very core of your experience. So the question for us has been, how do we build these ideas?
怎么说呢？我们注意到的一件事是，这种关于时间的观念，当然是由我们的思想和大脑高度建构出来的。所以你看不到时间，你摸不到时间，你闻不到或尝不到时间。但它是人类体验中完全至关重要的一部分。当然，你也无法体验到时间之外的任何事物。它正是你体验的本质，是你体验的核心。所以对我们来说，问题在于：我们是如何构建这些概念的？
It's not just about how we think about time. It's how we think about anything that's abstract, that's beyond our physical senses. And one thing that we've noticed is that around the world, people rely on space to organize time. So, for example, for English speakers, people who read from left to right, time tends to flow from left to right.
这不仅关乎我们如何思考时间。这关乎我们如何思考任何抽象的、超越我们身体感官的事物。我们注意到的一件事是，世界各地的人们都依靠空间来组织时间。例如，对英语使用者来说，也就是从左到右阅读的人，时间往往是从左到右流动的。
So, earlier things are on the left, later things are on the right. If I give you a bunch of pictures to lay out and say, this is telling you some kind of story, and they're disorganized when an English speaker organizes those pictures, they'll organize them from left to right. But if I give that same story to a Hebrew and Arabic speaker, they would organize it from right to left. That is the direction of writing in Hebrew and Arabic
所以，较早的事情在左边，较晚的事情在右边。如果我给你一堆图片让你摆放，并说，这在讲述某种故事，而它们是杂乱无章的，当一个英语使用者整理这些图片时，他们会从左到右进行整理。但如果我把同一个故事给希伯来语和阿拉伯语使用者，他们会从右到左整理。这就是希伯来语和阿拉伯语的书写方向——
going from right to left. But time doesn't have to flow with respect to the body, so to go back to the example, we were just talking about people who don't use words like left and right. When I gave those picture stories to cooktire speakers who use North-South East and West, they organized the cards from East to West. And so what that means is if someone was sitting facing south, they would lay out the story from left to right. But if they're sitting facing north, they would lay out the story from right to left. And if they're facing east, they would make the carts come towards them toward the body. So that's an example of how languages and cultures construct how we use space to
从右到左。但时间不一定非要顺应身体流动，所以回到我们刚才讨论的例子，那些不使用“左”和“右”等词的人。当我把那些图片故事交给使用东、南、西、北的库克泰尔语使用者时，他们是从东到西排列卡片的。这意味着，如果有人面向南方坐着，他们会从左到右排列故事。但如果他们面向北方坐着，他们就会从右到左排列故事。如果他们面向东方，他们会把卡片朝向自己、朝向身体拉过来。这就是语言和文化如何构建我们如何利用空间来
organize time, to organize this very abstract thing that's otherwise kind of hard to get our hands on and think about. If languages are shaped by the way people see the world but they also shape how people see the world, what does this mean for people who are bilingual? If you can speak more than one language, does this mean that you're also simultaneously and constantly shifting in your mind between different worldviews? That's a wonderful question. So one possibility for bilinguals would be that they just have two different minds inside, right? So one one one skull but two different minds and you shift from one to the other. Another possibility is that it's a fully integrated mind,
组织时间、组织这个原本很难让人捉摸和思考的极度抽象的事物的一个例子。如果语言是由人们看待世界的方式塑造的，但它们同时也塑造了人们看待世界的方式，这对双语者意味着什么？如果你能说不止一种语言，这是否意味着你的大脑也在不同的世界观之间同时且不断地切换？这是一个绝妙的问题。所以对双语者来说，一种可能性是他们的大脑里其实有两个不同的心智，对吧？也就是一个头颅里有两个不同的心智，你在两者之间切换。另一种可能性是，这是一个完全整合的心智，
and it just incorporates ideas and distinctions from both languages, or from many languages if you speak more than two. What turns out to be the case is that it's something in between that bilinguals don't really turn off the languages they're not using when they're not using them. So even if I'm speaking English, the distinctions that I've learned in speaking Russian, for example, are still active in my mind to some extent.
它只是吸收了两种语言（如果你会说两种以上的语言，则是多种语言）的想法和区别。事实证明，介于两者之间的是，双语者在不用某种语言时，并不会真正关闭它。所以即使我在说英语，例如我在说俄语时学到的那些区别，在我的脑海中在某种程度上仍然是活跃的。
But they're more active if I'm actually speaking Russian. So bilinguals are kind of this in-between case where they can't quite turn off their other languages, but they become more prominent, more salient when you're actually speaking the language or surrounded by the language. So, I want to talk about a debate that's raged in your field for many years. There are many scholars who would say, look, yes, you do see small differences between speakers of different languages, but these differences are not really significant. They're really small. How big are the differences that we're
但如果我实际在说俄语，它们就会更活跃。所以双语者处于这种中间状态，他们无法完全关闭他们的其他语言，但当你真正说该语言或被该语言包围时，它们会变得更加突出、更加显眼。所以，我想聊一个在你的领域激烈争论了多年的辩论。有许多学者会说，听着，是的，不同语言的使用者之间确实存在微小的差异，但这些差异并不是真的很大。它们真的很小。我们讨论的差异究竟有多大，
talking about and how big do you think the implications are for the way we see the world? Yeah, so there are some differences that are as big as you can possibly measure, for example, when we started talking about navigation, that's an example where a five-year-old in a culture that uses words like North South East and West can point southeast without hesitation. They know which way is which.
你认为这对我们看待世界的观点意味着什么？是的，有些差异大到你无法想象的程度，例如，当我们开始谈论导航时，这是一个例子：在一个使用“东南西北”等词汇的文化中，一个五岁的孩子可以毫不犹豫地指出东南方。他们知道哪个方向是哪个方向。
And very competent adults of our culture can't do that. So that's a measurement difference of 100% of performance. There's not a bigger difference you could find than 100% of the measurement space. You also see huge differences in other domains like number. So some languages don't have number words.
而我们文化中非常称职的成年人却做不到这一点。所以这是表现上 100% 的测量差异。你找不到比 100% 测量空间更大的差异了。你在数字等其他领域也能看到巨大的差异。有些语言没有数字词。
And if you don't have a word for exactly seven, it actually becomes very, very hard to keep track of exactly seven. And that is an example of a simple feature of language. Number words, acting as a transformative stepping stone to a whole domain of knowledge. Of course, if you can't keep track of exactly seven, you can't count. You're also not going to do algebra. You're not going to do trigonometry, you're not going to do any of the things that are seen as
如果你没有一个词来准确表达“七”，那么要准确记录“七”实际上就会变得非常非常困难。这就是语言的一个简单特征的例子。数字词充当了一个变革性的基石，通向了整个知识领域。当然，如果你无法准确追踪七，你就无法数数。你也不会做代数。你不会做三角函数，你也不会做任何被视为
a foundation of our technological society. So that again is a huge difference. So in terms of the size of differences, there are certainly effects that are really, really big. But things can be important, not just because they're big, they can be small differences, but important in other ways. So for example, grammatical gender. Because grammatical gender applies to all nouns in your language, that means that language is shaping the way you think about everything
我们技术社会基础的事情。所以这又是一个巨大的差异。因此，就差异的规模而言，确实有些影响非常非常大。但事物之所以重要，不仅因为它们规模大，它们可能存在微小的差异，但在其他方面同样重要。例如，语法性别。由于语法性别适用于你语言中的所有名词，这意味着语言正在塑造你对可以用名词命名的所有事物的看法。
that can be named by a noun. Well, that's an incredibly large set of things. So, that's a very broad effect of language. So, to give you a very quick wrap-up is that some effects are big, but even when the effects aren't big, they can be interesting or important for other reasons, either because they're very broad or because they apply to things that we think are really important in our culture. or because they apply to things that we think are really important in our culture. Languages orient us to the world. They shape our place in it. When we come back, we dig further into the way that gender works in different languages and the pervasive effects that words can play in our lives.
好吧，这是一个极其庞大的事物集合。所以，这是语言的一个非常广泛的影响。总之，简而言之，有些影响很大，但即使影响不大，它们出于其他原因也可能有趣或重要，要么是因为它们非常广泛，要么是因为它们适用于我们认为在文化中非常重要的事物。或者因为它们适用于我们认为在文化中非常重要的事物。语言引导我们走向世界。它们塑造了我们在其中的位置。当我们回来时，我们将进一步深入探讨性别在不同语言中的运作方式，以及词汇在我们生活中发挥的无处不在的影响。
Stay with us. I'm Shankar Vedanthantham and you're listening to Hidden Brain. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. We're speaking today with cognitive science professor Lera Boroditski about language. In many languages, nouns are gendered. La forchet. Le kuto diyaka. Der mantel. Melaka. Sikin. The word chair is feminine in Italian.
请继续收听。我是香卡·维丹塔姆，您正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》。这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是香卡·维丹塔姆。今天我们邀请到认知科学教授勒拉·博里茨基来聊聊语言。在许多语言中，名词是有性别的。La forchet（法语的叉子，阴性）。Le kuto diyaka（德语的刀，阳性）。Der mantel（德语的大衣，阳性）。Melaka（俄语的牛奶，阴性）。Sikin。在意大利语中，“椅子”这个词是阴性的。
But masculine in German. They're stool. I ask Lara how describing the word chair or the word bridge as masculine or feminine changes the way that speakers of different languages think about those concepts. Actually, one of the first people to notice or suggest that this might be the case was a Russian linguist Roman Yackepsen and he started by asking Russian speaking students to personify days of the week. So act like Monday or act like Wednesday. Sridha. And Russian is a language that has grammatical gender. Different days of the week have different genders for some reason.
但在德语中是阳性的。Der stool（德语的椅子）。我问勒拉，将“椅子”或“桥”描述为阳性或阴性，是如何改变不同语言使用者对这些概念的看法的。事实上，最早注意到或提出这一可能性的学者之一是俄语语言学家罗曼·雅各布森，他首先让说俄语的学生将一周中的日子拟人化。比如表现得像星期一或表现得像星期三。Sridha（星期三）。而俄语是一门具有语法性别的语言。由于某种原因，一周中的不同日子有不同的性别。
And what he noticed was that when people were trying to act like Monday, they would act like a man. Pani-deel-nik. And when they were trying to act like Wednesday, they would act like a woman. Sridha. Which accords with grammatical gender in Russian. And so he suggested it might be the case that the arbitrarily assigned grammatical genders are actually changing the way people think about these days of the
他注意到的是，当人们试图表现得像星期一（Pani-deel-nik，俄语中星期一为阳性）时，他们会表现得像个男人。而当他们试图表现得像星期三（Sridha，俄语中星期三为阴性）时，他们会表现得像个女人。这与俄语中的语法性别相吻合。因此他提出，这种被任意分配的语法性别实际上正在改变人们对这些星期几的看法，
week and maybe all kinds of other things that are named by nouns. So we've done a lot of studies looking at how speakers of Spanish and German in Russian actually think about objects that have opposite grammatical genders. Take the word bridge, if it's feminine in your language, you're more likely to say that bridges are beautiful and elegant. And if the word bridges masculine in your language are more likely to say that bridges are strong and long and towering, these kind of more stereotypically masculine words. And of course, you always have to wonder,
也许还有各种其他由名词命名的东西。所以我们做了大量研究，观察西班牙语、德语和俄语的使用者实际上是如何思考那些具有相反语法性别的物体的。以“桥”这个词为例，如果它在你的语言中是阴性的，你更有可能会说桥梁是美丽而优雅的。如果“桥”这个词在你的语言中是阳性的，你更有可能会说桥梁是坚固、漫长而高耸的，这些更具刻板印象的阳性词汇。当然，你总是会想，
well, could it be that speakers of these different languages are actually seeing different kinds of bridges? So maybe they're saying bridges are beautiful and elegant, not because they're grammatically feminine in the language, but because the bridges they have are, in fact, more beautiful and elegant. And so to address that question, what we do is we bring English speakers into the lab
好吧，会不会是这些不同语言的使用者实际上看到了不同种类的桥梁？所以也许他们说桥梁美丽而优雅，不是因为它们在语言中是语法上的阴性，而是因为他们拥有的桥梁实际上就更美丽、更优雅？为了解决这个问题，我们做的是把英语使用者带进实验室，
and we teach them grammatical genders in a new language that we invent. We call this language, Gumbuzzi. And we teach them, for example, to say that bridges and apples and all kinds of other things have the same prefix as women. So the word for the is different for women than for men, and it's also different for forks versus spoons and things like that. And what we find is that if you teach people that forks go with men, grammatically in a language, they start to think of forks as being more masculine.
并教他们在我们发明的一种新语言中使用语法性别。我们把这种语言叫做贡布齐语（Gumbuzzi）。我们教他们，例如，说桥梁、苹果和各种其他东西与女性有相同的前缀。所以表示“这个”的词对女性和男性是不同的，对叉子与勺子等也是不同的。我们的发现是：如果你在语法上教导人们叉子与男性搭配，他们就会开始认为叉子更具阳刚之气。
And if you teach them that forks go with women, they start to think that forks are more feminine. The categorization that language provides to you becomes real, becomes psychologically real. One study that I love is a study that asked monolingual speakers of Italian and German, and also bilingual speakers of Italian and German, to give reasons for why things are the grammatical genders that they are.
如果你教导他们叉子与女性搭配，他们就会开始认为叉子更具阴柔之美。语言为你提供的分类变得真实，在心理上变得真实。我非常喜欢的一项研究是，它要求意大利语和德语的单语使用者，以及意大利语和德语的双语使用者，为事物具有特定语法性别的原因给出解释。
So for example, if the word chair is masculine in language, why is that? If you're a monolingual speaker of one of these languages, you're very likely to say that the word chair is masculine because chairs are in fact masculine. Right, so these speakers have internalized this idea from their language and they believe that it's right. They believe that their language reflects the true structure of the world. If you ask bilinguals who've learned two languages and now they know that some genders disagree
例如，如果“椅子”这个词在某种语言中是阳性的，为什么会这样？如果你是其中一种语言的单语使用者，你极有可能会说“椅子”这个词是阳性的，因为椅子本身确实是阳性的。没错，这些使用者已经从他们的语言中内化了这种观点，并且他们相信这是对的。他们相信他们的语言反映了世界的真实结构。如果你去问那些学习了两种语言、现在知道某些性别的词在两种语言中存在分歧的双语者，
across the two languages, they're much less likely to say that it's because chairs are intrinsically masculine. They're more likely to say, well, it's a formal property of the language. They're more likely to see through this little game that language is played on them. I understand that there's also been studies
他们就不太会说这是因为椅子本质上是阳性的。他们更有可能会说，好吧，这是语言的一种形式属性。他们更有可能看穿语言对他们玩弄的这个小把戏。我听说还有一些研究探讨说不同语言的艺术家可能会根据他们的语言如何将山脉或死亡等概念分类，从而画出不同的画作。
looking at how artists who speak different languages might paint differently depending on how their languages categorize concepts like a mountain or death. Yeah, so we did an analysis of images in art store. This is a database with millions of art images. And we looked at every personification and allegory in art store and asked, does the language that you speak matter for how you paint death, depending on whether the word death is masculine or feminine
是的，所以我们对艺术商店（Artstor）中的图像进行了分析。这是一个拥有数百万艺术图像的数据库。我们查看了艺术商店中的每一个拟人和寓意形象，并提出了一个问题：你所说的语言是否会影响你描绘死亡的方式，这取决于“死亡”这个词在你的语言中是阳性还是阴性。
in your language. And to our surprise, 78% of the time, we could predict the gender of the personification based on the grammatical gender of the noun in the artist's native language. So if the word for death was masculine in your language, you were likely to paint death as a man. And if it was feminine and you're likely to paint death as a woman. The size of this effect really quite surprised me because I would have thought at the outset that artists are these iconic lasts they're supposed to
令我们惊讶的是，在 78% 的情况下，我们可以根据艺术家母语中名词的语法性别来预测其拟人形象的性别。所以如果“死亡”这个词在你的语言中是阳性的，你很可能会把死亡画成一个男人。如果是阴性的，你很可能会把死亡画成一个女人。这种影响的程度确实让我感到惊讶，因为我原本以为艺术家是一群打破传统的人，他们应该在画一些非常个人的东西，但事实上，他们却在反映语法上的这个小怪癖，他们语言的这个小怪癖，在某些情况下，你知道，将这些语法的怪癖凿进石头里，因为当你看看我们周围关于自由女神、正义女神之类的雕像时，它们都是有性别的。那是自由女神和正义女神。这些简直就是刻在石头里的语法怪癖。我们的对话让我好奇，
be painting something very personal but in fact they were reflecting this little quirk of grammar, this little quirk of their language and in some cases you know carving those quirks of grammar into stone because when you look at statues that we have around liberty and justice and things like this, they have gender. It's lady liberty and lady justice. Those are quirks of grammar literally in stone. Our conversation made me wonder
画的其实是非常私人的东西，但实际上它们反映了这种语法的奇特之处，也就是他们语言的奇特性，在某些情况下，你知道，甚至将这些语法的奇特性刻在石头上。因为当你看看我们周围关于自由、正义之类的雕像时，它们都是有性别的。那是自由女神和正义女神。这些语法上的奇特性简直就是刻在石头上的。我们的对话让我不禁好奇
about what this means on a larger scale. There's a speaker of a language like Spanish who has to assign gender to so many things and up seeing the world as more gendered. Lara said there's still a lot of research to be done on this, but she told me a story about a conversation she had with a native speaker of Indonesian. I spoke really terrible Indonesian at the time, so I was trying to practice. And I was telling this person about someone I knew back in America, and they asked me all kinds of questions about them.
这在更大范围内意味着什么。比如一个说西班牙语的人，必须给那么多东西指定性别，最终会不会把世界看得更有性别色彩？勒拉说，这方面还有很多研究要做，但她给我讲了一个故事，关于她和一个印度尼西亚语母语者的一次对话。“当时我的印尼语说得非常糟糕，所以我一直在练习。我跟这个人聊起了我在美国的一个熟人，他们向我问了关于这个人的各种问题。”
And then question 21 was, is this person a man or a woman? And I thought, wow, first of all, it would be almost impossible to have a conversation like that in English where you hadn't already revealed the gender of the person because you have to use he or she. But also I started wondering, is it possible that my friend here was imagining a person without a gender for this whole time that we've been talking about them, right? So when I ask you to say, imagine a man walking down the street. Well, in your imagery, you're going to have some details completed and some will be left out. So for example, you might not imagine the color shirt
然后第 21 个问题是：“这个人是男的还是女的？”我想，哇，首先，在英语中进行这样的对话几乎是不可能的，因为你还没透露过这个人的性别，因为你必须使用“他”或“她”。但同时我也开始纳闷，有没有可能我这位朋友在我俩谈论此人的整个过程中，一直在想象一个没有性别的人，对吧？所以当我要求你想象一个男人走在街上时。好吧，在你的意象中，一些细节会被补全，而另一些细节则会被忽略。例如，你可能不会想象他穿的衬衫的颜色，或者他穿的鞋子的种类。这种细节可能不会出现。所以很容易让人觉得，哦，我可以想象某个人，而不用明确去想他们穿的是什么。但是，你能想象一个人却不想象他的性别吗？
that he's wearing or the kinds of shoes that he's wearing. That kind of detail may not appear. So it's easy to think, oh, I could imagine someone without thinking explicitly about what they're wearing. But can you imagine someone without imagining their gender? Right. And so for me, that question was born in that conversation of, are there some languages where it's easier to imagine a person without their characteristics of gender filled in? So you can think about
没错。所以对我来说，那个问题就诞生于那场对话中：有没有某些语言，让人更容易想象一个没有性别特征的人？这样你就可以思考一个无性别的人，就像我思考一个没有特定年龄、没有特定身高或没有特定衬衫颜色的人一样。我认为这是一个对未来研究非常迷人的问题。所以这就引出了一个问题：如果可以把语言放在某种光谱上，比如西班牙语或印地语，
an ungendered person in the same way that I might think about a person without a specific age or a specific height or a specific color shirt. I think it's a really fascinating question for future research. So this begs the question, if you would, to put languages on something of a spectrum where you have, you know, languages like Spanish or Hindi,
名词是有性别的；而像英语这样的语言，许多名词虽然没有性别，但代词是有性别的；而在光谱的另一端，比如芬兰语或波斯语，你可以在不提及某人性别的情况下与人交谈，如果这在某种程度上没有转化为人们对性别的看法以及他们的日常活动，那将是令人惊讶的。就思考甚至谁能在职场中做些什么而言，这会不会影响我们世界中显性或隐性性别歧视的运作方式？这完全有可能。
where nouns are gendered and languages like English, where many nouns are not gendered, but pronouns are gendered. And on the other end of this spectrum, you know, languages like Finnish or Persian, where you can have a conversation about someone without actually mentioning their gender, it would seem surprising if this did not translate at some level into the way people thought about gender and their daily activities. In terms of thinking about maybe even who can do what in the workplace that could this affect the way sexism conscious or unconscious operates in our world? It's certainly possible.
我认为语言肯定会成为我们关于性别的复杂思考系统的一个推动因素。实际上，有一些经济学家对此进行过一些研究。他们比较了世界卫生组织的性别平等、性别对等规范，该组织根据各性别在获得教育的平等程度、薪酬平等程度以及在政府中的代表性平等程度对各国进行排名，并将其与语言中的性别特征进行了关联，
I think language can certainly be a contributor into the complex system of our thinking about gender. There's been a little bit of research from economists actually looking at this. So they've compared gender equality, gender parity norms from the World Health Organization, which ranks countries on how equal access to education, how equal pay is, how equal representation in government is across the genders. And they have correlated this with gender features in the
就像你刚才谈到的那些。他们认为，不同语言之间的差异确实在一定程度上预测了各国的这些性别平等指标。我听说有一些针对儿童的研究表明，说某些语言的儿童实际上比正在学习其他语言和文化儿童能更快地识别性别以及他们自己的性别。是的，没错。亚历山大·焦罗（Alexander Giorro）做过这些精彩的研究，他让学习芬兰语、英语和希伯来语作为第一语言的孩子们回答：基本上，你是男孩还是女孩？孩子们需要花一点时间才能弄清楚这一点，他想出了各种巧妙的方法来问这些问题。例如，他可能会拿出一堆男孩和女孩的照片并进行分类，然后说，好吧，这是一个男孩，它放在这堆里，一个女孩放在这堆里，然后他会拍一张孩子的宝丽来照片并说，好吧，这是你，你属于哪一堆？对吧？他发现的是，正在学习希伯来语的孩子们——
language, just like the ones you were talking about. And they suggest that differences across languages do, in fact, predict some of these measures of gender equality across countries. I understand there's been some work looking at children and that children who speak certain languages are actually quicker to identify gender and their own gender, then children who are learning other languages and other cultures. Yeah, that's true. So there are these wonderful studies by Alexander Giorro where he asked kids learning Finnish,
这门语言带有很强的性别色彩——
English, and Hebrew as their first languages. Basically, are you a boy or girl? This takes kids a little while to figure out, and he had all kinds of clever ways to ask these questions. For example, he might take a bunch of pictures of boys and girls and sort them and say, okay, this is a boy, it goes in this pile, a girl goes in this pile, and then he would take a polaroid of the kid and say, well, this is you, which pile do you go in? Right? And what he found was kids who are learning Hebrew. This is a language that has a lot of gender loading in it,
弄清楚自己是男孩还是女孩的时间，比正在学习芬兰语（语言中没有太多性别标记）的孩子们要早大约一年。当然，芬兰语的孩子们最终也弄明白了，因为语言并不是这种信息的唯一来源，否则芬兰人若不是靠偶然相遇，还能设法继续繁衍后代，那就相当令人惊讶了。但这是一个极好的例子，说明了语言如何引导你发现关于世界的某些事情，如果你语言中没有这些信息，你可能需要花更长时间才能发现。语言似乎有着不同的沟通施事性的方式。所以在英语中，我可能会说“萨姆打破了长笛”，但我听说在西班牙语中，表达方式会完全不同。
figured out whether they're a boy or a girl about a year sooner than kids learning Finnish, which doesn't have a lot of gender marking in the language. Of course, eventually the Finnish kids also figured it out because language isn't the only source of that information, otherwise it would be quite surprising for the Finns to be able to continue to reproduce themselves, but somehow they've managed not just by randomly bumping into each other. But it's a lovely example of how language can guide you to discover something about the world that
是的，许多语言会对意外和故意行为做出区分。例如，如果萨姆抓起一把锤子，愤怒地砸向长笛，那将是一种描述，就像“萨姆打破了长笛”一样。但如果他只是撞到了桌子，长笛碰巧从桌子上掉下来摔碎了，这是一个意外，那么你更有可能会说：长笛碎了，或者长笛自己碎了，或者萨姆碰巧把长笛弄碎了。你会用不同的描述来标明这不是故意的。
might take you longer to discover if you didn't have that information in language. Languages seem to have different ways of communicating agency. So in English, I might say that SAM broke the flute, but I understand that in Spanish, this would come out quite differently. Yeah, lots of languages make a distinction between things that are accidents and things that are intentional actions. So for example, if Sam grabbed a hammer and struck the flute in an anger, that would be one description like Sam broke the flute.
实际上在英语中，相当奇怪的是，我们甚至可以说出这样的话：“我摔断了胳膊。”在很多语言中，你不能这样说，因为除非你疯了，出门去找断胳膊并且成功了，
But if he just bumped into the table and it happened to fall off the table and break and it was an accident, then you might be more likely to say, the flute broke or the flute broke itself or it so happened to Sam that the flute broke. You would give a different description to Mark that it was not intentional. In English, actually, quite weirdly, we can even say things like, I broke my arm. A lot of languages, you can't say that because unless you were crazy and you went out looking to break your arm and you succeed it,
否则你得说类似“我的胳膊断了”或者“我的胳膊碰巧断了”。这通常不是你故意去做的事情。这会对人们如何思考事件、当他们看到意外时注意到什么产生影响。例如，英语使用者因为非常倾向于说“他做了这个”或“某人做了这个”，所以他们非常擅长记住是谁做的，即使这是一个意外，
you would have to say something like, my arm got broken or it so happened to me that my arm is broken. It's not something that you typically go up trying to do intentionally. And there are consequences for how people think about events, what they notice when they see accidents. So for example, English speakers, because they're very likely to say he did it or someone did it, they are very good at remembering who did it, even if it's an accident,
而西班牙语等语言的使用者可能不太擅长在发生意外时记住是谁干的，但他们更擅长记住这是一个意外。所以说两种不同语言的人看着同一个事件，却会因为其语言结构以及他们通常描述该事件的方式而带着对发生事情的不同记忆离开。在世界各地，我们经常听到许多语言正在消亡，而有少数巨型语言在以各种方式成长和扩张。如果你接受语言是看待世界、感知现实的一种非常具体且独特的方式这一观点，你认为这意味着什么？在我们的时代，如此多的语言消失意味着什么？
whereas speakers of language like Spanish might not be quite as good at remembering who did it when it's an accident, but they're better at remembering that it was an accident. So you have speakers of two different languages look at the same event and come away with different memories of what happened because of the structure of their languages and the way they would normally describe that. Around the world, we often hear that many languages are dying and and there are a few mega languages that are growing and expanding in all kinds of ways. What do you think the implications are if you if you buy the idea that languages are
嗯，我认为这是一场可怕的悲剧。每一种语言都包含了文化中历经数千代人摸索出来的思想。每当一种语言消亡时，这就是一笔惊人的文化遗产和思想复杂性的消失。麻省理工学院语言学家肯·海尔（Ken Hale），这位著名的语言学家曾说过，每有一种语言消亡，就相当于一颗炸弹投向了卢浮宫。这就是损失了这么多的文化遗产。有些人可能会说这更多，
a very specific and unique way of seeing the world of perceiving reality? What are the implications of so many languages disappearing during our time? Well, I think it's a terrible tragedy. Each language comprises the ideas that have been worked out in a culture over thousands of generations. And that is an incredible amount of cultural heritage and complexity of thought that disappears whenever a language dies. MIT linguist Ken Hale, the renowned linguist, said that every time a language dies, it's the equivalent of a bomb being dropped on the Louvre. That's how much cultural heritage is lost. And some people would say it's a lot more
因为它是无法恢复的，在其他地方也无法复制。世界各地的所有语言中都存在着各种有趣、有用、大开眼界的思想。所以我认为我们正在失去所有这些语言多样性、所有这些文化多样性，是一场不可思议的悲剧，因为这是人类的遗产。这是对人类心灵不可思议的创造力和复杂性的证明，所有这些对世界的不同视角都被发明了出来。令人难过的是，我们将无法利用它们、学习它们并赞美它们。
because it's you know irrecoverable and not reduplicated elsewhere. And there are all kinds of interesting, useful eye-opening ideas that exist in all of the world's languages. So I think it's an incredible tragedy that we're losing all of this linguistic diversity, all of this cultural diversity because it is human heritage. It's testament to the incredible ingenuity and complexity of the human mind that all of these different perspectives on the world have been invented. And it's sad that we're not going to be able to make use of them and learn them and celebrate them.
勒拉·博里茨基是加州大学圣迭戈分校的认知科学教授。勒拉，非常感谢你今天做客《隐藏的大脑》。非常感谢邀请我。如果你有青少年或者与年轻人密切合作过，你很可能会对他们的对话感到困惑，甚至恼火。年轻人总是以新颖不同的方式使用语言，而且这几乎总是把老年人逼疯。
Lara Borditsky is a cognitive science professor at the University of California, San Diego. Lara, thank you so much for joining me on Hidden Brain today. Thank you so much for having me. If you have teenagers or work closely with young people, chances are you've been mystified by their conversations, or even annoyed. Young people have always used language in new and different ways, and it's pretty much always driven older people crazy.
所有的“like”和字面意思的“literally”有时可能会让你感到刺耳，但约翰·麦克沃特（John McWhorter）说，问题可能出在你身上，而不是出在其他人说话的方式上。约翰是哥伦比亚大学的英语与比较文学教授。他也是《语言在流动：为什么英语过去、现在和将来都不会一成不变，简直如此》（Words on the Move, Why English Won't and Can't Sit Still, Like Literally）一书的作者。约翰·麦克沃特，欢迎来到《隐藏的大脑》。谢谢。我们许多人在家里或工作场所都有字典，约翰，而你说字典在
All of the likes and, like, literalize might sometimes great on your nerves, but John McWater says, the problem might be with you, not with the way other people speak. John is a professor of English and comparative literature at Columbia University. He is also the author of the book, Words on the Move, Why English Won't and Can't Sit Still, Like Literally. John McWater Welcome to Hidden Brain. Thank you. Many of us have dictionaries at home or at work, John, and you say that dictionaries in
所有的“like”和诸如此类的词，或者说“literally”（简直/真正地），有时可能会让你感到心烦意乱，但约翰·麦克沃特（John McWhorter）说，问题可能出在你身上，而不是出在别人的说话方式上。约翰是哥伦比亚大学的英语和比较文学教授。他也是《语言在流动：为什么英语不会也不可能静止不动，就像字面意思那样》（Words on the Move, Why English Won't and Can't Sit Still, Like Literally）一书的作者。约翰·麦克沃特，欢迎来到《隐藏的大脑》（Hidden Brain）。谢谢。约翰，我们很多人家里或单位都有字典，而你说字典在
some ways paint an unrealistic portrait of a language. They give us a sense that the meanings of words are fixed when in fact they're not. Yeah, dictionaries are wonderful things, but they create an illusion that there's such thing as a language that stands still. When really, it's the nature of human language to change. Each generation hears things and interprets things slightly differently from the previous one. I mean, just in terms of even sounds changing, in the way that you put words together changing bit by bit. And there's never been a language that didn't do that. I love this analogy you have in the book where you mention how, you know, thinking that a
有些方面对语言的描绘并不真实。它们让我们觉得词义是固定不变的，但实际上并非如此。是的，字典是很棒的东西，但它们制造了一种错觉，仿佛真的有一种语言是静止不动的。而实际上，不断变化才是人类语言的本质。每一代人听到的事物以及对事物的理解，都与前一代人略有不同。我的意思是，仅仅就发音的变化而言，你把词语组合在一起的方式也在一点一点地改变。从来没有哪种语言不发生这种变化。我很喜欢你在书中的那个比喻，你提到认为一个
word has only one meaning is like looking at a snapshot taken at one point in a person's life and saying, this photograph represents the entirety of what this person looks like. Exactly. It's as if you saw a person, I'm not going to say it for, because then the person is growing up and if I use that analogy, then it seems like I'm saying that language grows up where it moves towards something or it develops. Imagine you meet somebody there thirty-nine and you take their picture and then ten years later when they're forty-nine you say well that picture of you at thirty-nine is what you really are and whatever has happened to you since then is some sort of disaster or something that shouldn't have happened.
词只有一个意思，就像看着一个人在人生某个阶段拍的快照，然后说这张照片代表了这个人的全部长相。完全正确。这就好像你看到一个人——我先不说那个词，因为接下来这个人会长大，如果我用了那个比喻，那就好像我在说语言会长大，会朝着某个方向发展或进化。想象一下，你遇到了一个三十-九岁的人，你给他们拍了照，然后十年后当他们四十九岁时，你说，好吧，你三十-九岁时的那张照片才是真正的你，从那以后发生在你身上的任何事都是某种灾难，或者是不该发生的事情。
How come you aren't exactly the way you were 10 years ago? That's the way words are too. But it's so hard to feel that. Partly because our brains are on writing, as I say in the book, we can't help as literate people thinking that the real language is something that sits still with letters written all nice and pretty on a page that can exist for hundreds of years. But that's not what language has ever been, only a couple hundred languages.
你怎么不像10年前那样了？词语也是这样的。但这种感觉很难体会到。部分原因是因为我们的脑子局限于书面文字，正如我在书中说的，作为识字的人，我们忍不住会认为真正的语言是那种静止不动的、字词漂漂亮亮地写在纸上、能够存在几百年的东西。但语言从来都不是那样的，只有区区几百种语言是这样的。
If you want to be conservative about it, a hundred languages are written in any real way. And then there are 6,800 others. Language is something that's spoken, and spoken language, especially always keeps changing. It's inherent. One of the points you make in the book, of course, is that the evolution of words and their meanings is what gives us this flowering of hundreds or thousands of languages, mistakes and errors, are what turn Latin into French?
如果你对这个数字持保守态度的话，有一百种语言是以真正的方式书写出来的。然后还有其他6,800种语言。语言是用来口头表达的，而口头语言，尤其是口头语言，总是在不断变化。这是它固有的特性。当然，你在书中提出的观点之一，就是词语及其意义的演变，才为我们带来了成百上千种语言的繁荣，而那些失误和错误，正是将拉丁语变成法语的原因吗？
Yes, that's exactly true. What we think of today as a word undergoing some odd development or people using some new construction is exactly how Latin turned into French. It's exactly how old English turned into modern English. And I don't think any of us are thinking that it's a shame that we're not using the language of Bayo Wolf. So I think that nobody would say that they don't think language should change. But what most people mean is that there'll be slang, that there'll be new words for new things, and that some of
是的，完全正确。我们今天认为正在经历某种奇怪演变的词汇，或者人们使用的新结构，正是拉丁语变成法语的过程。这也正是古英语变成现代英语的过程。我想我们谁都不会觉得，我们没有使用《贝奥武夫》时期的语言是一种遗憾。所以我想没有人会说他们认为语言不应该改变。但大多数人真正的意思是，会产生一些俚语，会有表达新事物的新词，并且其中一些
those words will probably come from other languages. But I don't think that it's always clear to us that language has to change in that things are going to come in, that we're going to hear as intrusions, or as irritating, or as mistakes, despite the fact that that's how you get from say old person to modern person and nobody wishes that we hadn't developed our modern languages today from the ancient versions. I want to talk in the second half of our conversation about why the meanings of words change, but I want to start by talking about how they change. Let's start with the word literally. It turns
词汇可能会来自其他语言。但我觉得我们并不总是那么清楚地意识到，语言必须要发生变化，新东西会涌现，而我们会把这些新东西听成是入侵、是烦人、或者错误——尽管事实正是通过这种方式，你才从所谓的古代人变成了现代人，而且没有人希望我们的现代语言没有从古代版本发展而来。在我们的第二部分对话中，我想讨论为什么词语的意义会发生改变，但我想先从它们是如何改变的开始谈起。让我们从“literally”（字面意思/简直）这个词开始。事实
out as you point out that in common usage literally literally means the opposite of literally. The second button literally makes our breaks the shirt. Look at it. It's too high. Dr. Harris, you are literally the meanest person I've ever met. In the first days, literally the first day, literally making it, and it irritates people. But there's a different way of seeing, literally. If you take literally in what we can think of as it's earliest meaning, the earliest meaning known to us is by the letter.
证明，正如你所指出的，在日常用法中，“literally”字面上的意思恰恰变成了“literally”的反义词。第二颗纽扣简直（literally）把衬衫撑破了。你看它。太高了。哈里斯博士，你简直（literally）是我遇到过最刻薄的人。在最初的几天里，简直（literally）就是第一天，简直（literally）就是这样，这让人们感到恼火。但看待“literally”还有另一种方式。如果你把“literally”理解为我们可以认为的最早含义，即我们所知的最早含义是“逐字地”。
And so somebody says something literally. Somebody takes a point literally. Well, if you have a word like that, and if it's an intensifier of that kind, you can almost guess that literally is going to come to mean something more like just really. So what happens is that once literally comes to feel like it means really, people start using it in figurative constructions such as I was literally dying of thirst. Now many people hear that and they think, well, that's no good because now literally
所以有人字面意思地说某事。有人字面意思地理解某个观点。嗯，如果你有这样一个词，如果它是一种那种程度的强化词，你几乎可以猜到，“literally”最终会变得更像是“真的”的意思。所以发生的情况是，一旦“literally”开始让人感觉它的意思是“真的”，人们就开妈在比喻性结构中使用它，例如“我当时渴得要死（literally dying of thirst）”。现在很多人听到这话就会想，嗯，这可不好，因为现在“literally”
can mean it's opposite. But we have plenty of words like that in English where it doesn't bother us at all. For example, if you take seeds and put them in the ground, that's one thing, but if you see a watermelon, nobody assumes that you're taking seeds and putting them in the watermelon, you're taking them out. Those are called contra nins and literally has become a new contra nim, it should be thought of as fun. One of the things I found really interesting is that the evolution of words and language is constant. So new words are as likely to evolve as old ones.
可以表示它的反义词了。但在英语中，我们有很多这样的词，它们一点也不会让我们感到困扰。例如，如果你把种子放进土里，这是一回事；但如果你看到一个西瓜，没有人会假设你是把种子放进西瓜里，你是在把它们拿出来。这些被称为兼兼词（contronyms），而“literally”已经成了新的兼兼词，我们应该觉得它很有趣。我发现非常有趣的一件事情是，词语和语言的演变是持续不断地。因此，新词和旧词演变的几率是一样的。
So LOL was an internet abbreviation, meaning laugh out loud or laughing out loud, but LOL and common usage today doesn't necessarily mean historical laughter. No, because LOL was an expression, it was a piece of language. And so you knew that its meaning was going to change. The only question was in which way. And then ended up becoming less a direct reflection of Hardy laughter than an indication of the kind of almost subconscious laughter that we do in any kind of conversation that's meant as friendly. It can be almost counterintuitive to listen to how much giggling and laughing you do. In ordinary, actually rather plain exchanges with people, it's part of a general running indication that everything's okay between you and the other
所以LOL是一个互联网缩写，意思是“大声笑出声来”（laugh out loud）或“笑出声”（laughing out loud），但LOL在今天的日常用法中并不一定指历史上的大笑。不，因为LOL是一个表达，它是一段语言。所以你知道它的意义将会改变。唯一的悬念是以什么方式改变。最终它变得不再是对酣畅大笑的直接反映，而是变成了一种几乎是潜意识中笑声的暗示——我们在任何旨在友好的对话中都会发出这种笑声。去听听你在对话中傻笑和笑得有多频繁，这有时会与直觉相反。在平常的、实际上相当平淡的交流中，它是你和对方之间一切正常的整体持续暗示，
person, just like one's expected to smile a little bit in most interactions. So, LOL starts out as meaning hardy, hard hard, hard, but then it becomes something more abstract. But the reason that it seems so elusive is because we don't really think about the quote-unquote meaning of things like our conversation easing laughter. As someone who spends a lot of his time listening to language evolve, John hears a lot of slang. He's a defender of language on the move, but I wanted to know if there were things that irritated even him. Oh yeah, I'm a human being, and so even though I insist that there is no scientific basis
就像在大多数互动中，人们被期望微微一笑一样。所以，LOL最初的意思是爽朗的大笑、大笑、大笑，但后来它变得更抽象了。但它之所以显得如此难以捉摸，是因为我们并不怎么去思考诸如“缓和对话气氛的笑声”这类词汇的“所谓”含义。作为经常花时间倾听语言演变的人，约翰听到了很多俚语。他是发展中的语言的捍卫者，但我很想知道，是否有些事情连他也会感到恼火。哦，是的，我是个人类，所以尽管我坚持认为没有任何科学依据
for rejecting some new word or some new meaning or some new construction. I certainly have my visceral biases. And so, for example, can I get a hamburger? Can I get some chicken? I've always found that a very grating way to ask for something at a store. It seems kind of elliptical. Like, would it be possible that I obtained? And then
来拒绝某个新词、某个新含义或某种新结构。我当然也有我本能的偏见。所以，举个例子，“Can I get a hamburger?”（我可以来个汉堡吗？）“Can I get some chicken?”（我可以来点鸡肉吗？）我一直觉得这是一种在店里点东西时非常刺耳的说法。它似乎有点省略。就像是，“是否有可能我获得？”然后
if you are going to be that elliptical, why use the casual word get? And it sounds a little bit abrupt and grabby like you're going to get something instead of being given. All of these are very subjective things. It's not necessarily may I please have, but may I have, I'll have, but not can I get a, I find it just vulgar for reasons that as you can see, I can't even do what I would call defending. It's just how I feel. And we're all going to have feelings like that. And when I listen to people having their peas, I don't think stop it.
如果你打算用这么省略的表达，为什么还要用“get”这个随意的词呢？它听起来有点突兀和贪婪，就像你要去“获取”什么东西，而不是被给予。所有这些都是非常主观的事情。这不一定非得是“may I please have”（请问我可以要……吗），而是“may I have”（我可以要……吗）、“I'll have”（我要……），但绝不是“can I get a”（我能拿一个……吗），我觉得它极其粗俗，原因正如你所看到的，我甚至无法进行我所谓的辩护。这只是我的感觉。我们所有人都会有这种感觉。当我听到别人说他们的话时，我不会想：住手。
But what I am thinking is you should realize that even if you don't like it, there's nothing wrong with it in the long run, because, for example, Jonathan Swift didn't like it, that people were saying kissed instead of kiss it, and rebuked instead of rebuked. He didn't like that people were shortening the words. How does that sound now? We don't want to be like that. All right, I think it might be time for me to confess one of my pet peeves. It has to do with the word momentarily. Growing up, I understood this word to mean for a very short time, as in John McWater was momentarily surprised. But I find that people now usually use the word to mean very soon, as in we're going to board the plane momentarily. The dictionary says both uses are correct. But you know John, something nauseate me every time I hear the word used wrong and after listening to you I realize I might have to finally give in. When we come back I'm going to ask you about why
但我在想的是：你应该意识到，即使你不喜欢它，从长远来看它也没有任何问题，因为，举个例子，乔纳森·斯威夫特（Jonathan Swift）就不喜欢人们把“kissed”说成“kist”，把“rebuked”说成“rebukt”。他不喜欢人们把词语缩写。现在听起来怎么样？我们可不想变成那样。好了，我想现在也许是我坦白一个我最讨厌的语言习惯的时候了。它与“momentarily”这个词有关。在成长过程中，我理解这个词的意思是“非常短暂的一段时间”，就像“约翰·麦克沃特感到短暂的惊讶”。但我发现人们现在通常用这个词来表示“很快”，比如“我们马上（momentarily）就要登机了”。字典上说这两种用法都是正确的。但是你知道吗，约翰，每次听到这个词被错误使用，我都觉得恶心，听了你的话后，我意识到我可能终于得妥协了。当我们回来时，我要问你为什么
languages change and whether there are hidden rules such shape, why some words are more likely to evolve than others. We'll be back momentarily. Stay with us. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantan. If you're just joining us, I'm talking to John McWater. He's a professor of English and comparative literature at Columbia University and the author of the book Words on the Move, why English won't and can't sit still, like literally. John, you've noted that humans have been using language for a very long time, but for most of that time language has been about talking. Writing has come along relatively recently. Are the spoken origins of language one reason
语言会发生变化，以及是否存在塑造这种变化的隐藏规则，为什么有些词比其他词更有可能演变。我们一会儿就回来。请继续收听。这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹坦。如果你刚加入我们的节目，我正在跟约翰·麦克沃特交谈。他是哥伦比亚大学英语与比较文学教授，也是《语言在演变：为什么英语不会也无法静止，正如“literally”一词》（Words on the Move, why English won't and can't sit still, like literally）一书的作者。约翰，你曾指出人类使用语言已经有很长一段时间了，但在大部分时间里，语言都是关于说话的。书面语出现得相对较晚。语言的口语起源是
that words so often seem to be on the move? origins of language one reason that words so often seem to be on the move? Yes, Shankar, that's exactly it. Language as it evolved was just talking to an extent that can be very hard for we literate people to imagine. There was no way of transcribing an approximation of what people said and nobody would have thought of doing it. Language was talk. When language was like that, of course it changed a lot. Fast, because once you said it, it was gone and if people heard the sounds a little differently and produced them a little differently, if there were new meanings of words very quickly, whatever the original meaning was wouldn't be remembered. There was no
词语似乎经常在演变的原因之一吗？语言的起源是词语似乎经常在演变的原因之一吗？是的，尚卡尔，完全是这样。随着语言的演变，它仅仅就是交谈，这种程度对于我们这些识字的人来说是很难想象的。当时没有办法转录人们所说话语的近似值，也没有人会想到去这么做。语言就是交谈。当语言是那样的时候，它当然会发生很多变化。速度很快，因为一旦你说出口，它就消失了；如果人们对声音的听感略有不同，发音也略有不同，如果词语产生了新含义，那么无论最初的含义是什么，都不会被记住。当时根本
such thing as looking up what it originally meant. And so language changed, just like the clouds in the sky, but then you start writing things down and you're in a whole new land, because once things are sitting there written on that piece of paper, there's that illusion. And it really is an illusion that what language is is something that sits still, there's a way of speaking right. And the way you speak right is not by speaking the way the people around you in your life speak, but by speaking the way the language is, as it sits there, all nice and pretty on that piece of paper where its reality exists.
不存在去查阅它最初是什么意思这回事。所以语言改变了，就像天上的云一样，但接着你开始把事情写下来，你就进入了一个全新的天地，因为一旦事情安安稳稳地写在那张纸上，就会产生一种错觉。这确实是一种错觉，即语言是某种静止不动的东西，有一种正确说话的方式。而正确说话的方式不是像你生活中周围的人那样说话，而是像语言本身那样说话——它安安稳稳、漂漂亮亮地存在于那张纸上，它的现实就存在于那里。
Would it be possible to use what we have learned about how words and languages evolve to potentially write what a dictionary might look like in 50 years or 100 years? You could have fun doing such a thing. The fact is that language change can always go in one of many directions as a chance element to it. So you can't know how the words are going to come out, but you can take good guesses. You know, endings are going to tend to drop off.
我们是否有可能利用我们对词语和语言如何演变的了解，来预测50年或100年后字典可能会是什么样子？做这件事会很有趣。事实是，语言的变化总是可以朝多个方向发展中的一个，其中包含偶然的因素。所以你无法确切知道词语最终会变成什么样，但你可以做出很好的猜测。你知道，词尾往往会脱落。
So if you took a bunch of those tendencies, you could make up, say, the English of 50 years from now. But some of the things would just be complete chance. You would never know, for example, that, give you an example I've actually been thinking about. Women under about 30 in the United States when they're excited or they're trying to underline a point, putting up at the end of things. And so somebody will say, well, who was it who you thought was gonna give you this present?
所以，如果你抓住了其中一堆趋势，你就可以编造出，比方说，50年后的英语。但有些事情完全是纯粹的偶然。举个例子，你永远不会知道——我给你举一个我实际上一直在思考的例子。美国30岁以下的女性在兴奋或者试图强调某个观点时，会在句尾加上一个“up”。所以有人会说：“Well, who was it who you thought was gonna give you this present?”（嗯，你以为是谁要给你这个礼物呢？）
You, and I mean, really, it sounds exactly like that. I know is there, or something along the lines of, babe! And as odd as that sounds, I can guarantee you, if you watch any TV show with women under a certain age, or if you just go out on an American street, and listen, you'll find that that's a new kind of exclamatory particle.
“You, and I mean, really, sounds exactly like that.”（你，我的意思是，真的，听起来完全是这样的。）“I know is there”（我知道就在那儿），或者类似“babe!”这样的话。尽管听起来很奇怪，但我向你保证，如果你看任何由某个年龄段以下的女性出演的电视节目，或者你只是走到美国街头去听一听，你会发现这是一种新型的感叹语。
That is the most random thing, and I would really guess that in a few decades, men will be doing it too, those sorts of things tend to start with women. You couldn't have predicted this, I know! Move! You can't know, but you can certainly know that if we could listen to people 50 years from now, they'd sound odd. Something new will have started by then, just like if we listen to people in 1971, they sound odd in that they don't say like. As much as we do, that hasn't started then. Imagine how we would sound to them if they could hear us. If you're so upset about it, maybe you can think of a way to help her.
这真的是最随机的事情了，我真的猜想几十年后，男性也会这么做，这类事情往往是从女性开始的。你不可能预测到这一点，我知道！动起来！你无法预知，但你绝对可以肯定的是，如果我们能听到50年后的人说话，他们听起来会很奇怪。到那时会有新的东西产生，就像如果我们听1971年的人说话，他们听起来也很奇怪，因为他们不像我们现在这样经常说“like”（像/那个啥）。那个时候还没有开始呢。想象一下，如果他们能听到我们说话，我们会听起来多奇怪。如果你对此这么心烦意乱，也许你能想出一个办法来帮帮她。
Right. You know, lots of people blow off steam about something they think is wrong, but very few people are willing to get involved and do something about it. I'm willing to get involved. So all this raises a really interesting question. You know, we spend years teaching children about how to use language correctly. As someone who works in media, I often find that people who can write well are often people who know how to think well. So I often equate clarity of writing with clarity of thought. How do you balance the imperative of teaching correct usage, which I think is
对。你知道的，很多人对他们认为错误的事情发泄怒气，但很少有人愿意参与进来并采取行动。我愿意参与进来。所以所有这一切提出了一个非常有趣的问题。你知道的，我们花了很多年教导儿童如何正确使用语言。作为一名媒体工作者，我经常发现，擅长写作的人往往也是擅长思考的人。所以我经常将写作的清晰等同于思维的清晰。你如何平衡教授正确用法的必要性——我认为这
probably important with the reality that this edifice that you're teaching is constantly crumbling? It's a matter of fashion, pure and simple. People do need to be taught what the socially acceptable forms are. But what we should teach is not that the good way is logical and the way that you're comfortable doing it is illogical, it should just be, here is the natural way. Then there's some things that you're supposed to do in public, because that's the way it is, whether it's fair or not. You can even teach people to have a little bit of fun with
可能很重要——与你所教导的这座大厦正在不断坍塌这一现实之间的关系？这纯粹是一个时尚问题。人们确实需要被教导什么是社会可接受的形式。但我们应该教导的不是“这种好的方式是合乎逻辑的，而你习惯的那种方式是不合乎逻辑的”，而应该仅仅是：“这是自然的方式。”然后有些事情是你被要求在公共场合去做的，因为事情就是这样，不管公平与否。你甚至可以教导人们对
the Artifist. But it's exactly like, it was maybe about 20 years ago, that somebody, a girlfriend I had told me that if I wore pants that had little vertical pleats up near the waist, then I was conveying that I was kind of past it. That was somehow a dad's fashion, and that I should start wearing flat, fronted pants. That is utterly arbitrary, that those little slits in American society look elderly. But for various chance reasons that's what those slits came to mean. So I started wearing flat fronted pants. That is exactly why you should say fewer books instead of less books in some situations. And yes, Billy and I went to the store rather than the perfectly natural
这种大厦（体制）觉得有点好玩。但这完全就像是，大概20年前，我的一位女朋友告诉我，如果我穿裤腰附近有小垂直褶皱的裤子，就是在传达我已经过时了。那不知怎么成了爸爸的时尚，我应该开始穿平腰前襟的裤子。这种认为美国社会中的那些小褶缝看起来显老的想法完全是专断的。但由于各种偶然的原因，那些褶缝就有了那种含义。所以我开始穿平腰前襟的裤子。这正是为什么在某些情况下你应该说“fewer books”（更少的书，用于可数名词）而不是“less books”（更少的书，通常用于不可数名词）。没错，“Billy and me went to the store”（比利和我去了商店，语法上应为Billy and I）比起完全自然的
Billy and me went to the store. Sometimes you just have to suck it up. But I think that we should learn not to listen to people using natural language as committing errors because there's no such thing as making a mistake in your language if a critical mass of other people speaking your language are doing the same thing. You make the case that concerns over the misuse of language might actually be one of the last places where people can publicly express prejudice and class differences. And as you point out, it's not just that people feel that a word is being misused, they often feel angry about it,
“Billy and me went to the store”更应该被避免。有时你只能咬牙接受。但我认为我们应该学会不要把使用自然语言的人视为在犯错，因为如果说你的语言的大多数关键人群都在这么做，那么在你的语言中根本就不存在犯错这回事。你提出了这样一个观点：对滥用语言的担忧实际上可能是人们公开表达偏见和阶级差异的最后阵地之一。正如你所指出的，不仅仅是人们觉得一个词被滥用了，他们常常对此感到愤怒，
and you think this anger is actually telling. Yeah, I really do. I think that the tone that many people use when they're complaining that somebody says, Billy and me went to the store is a little bit in commensurate with the significance of the issue. And I can't help surmising that part of it is that the educated American has been taught and often well that you're not supposed to look down
而你认为这种愤怒实际上说明了问题。是的，我真的这么认为。我认为许多人在抱怨别人说“Billy and me went to the store”时所使用的语气，与这个问题的严重性有点不相称。我不禁猜测，部分原因在于受过教育的美国人已经被教导（而且往往教得很好）——你不应该因为性别、种族、能力而看不起别人。
on people because of gender, because of race, because of ability. But might we allow that there's probably a part of all human beings that wants to look down on somebody else? What a cynical thing to say, but that doesn't mean that it might not be true. And if that is true, then the educated person can look down on people who say Billy and me went to the store or who are using literally quote-unquote wrong and condemn them in the kinds of terms that once were ordinary for condemning black people or women or what have you.
但是，我们是否可以承认，所有人类心中可能都有一部分想要看不起别人？说出这样的话真是愤世嫉俗，但这并不意味着它可能不是真的。如果这是真的，那么受过教育的人就可以看不起那些说“Billy and me went to the store”的人，或者那些“错误”使用“literally”这一引文的人，并用曾经用来谴责黑人、女性诸如此类群体的那些言辞来谴责他们。
So I just think that it's something we need to check ourselves for. It might irritate you slightly to hear somebody say something like, I need less books instead of fewer books. But does a person who says that really deserves the kind of sneering condemnation that you often see. There's a loaier part of our nature that grammar allows us to vent in the absence of other ways to do it that have not been available for some decades.
所以我只是觉得这是我们需要反省的一点。听到有人说出诸如“I need less books”而不是“fewer books”这样的话，可能会让你稍微有点恼火。但说这话的人真的配得上你经常看到的的那种冷嘲热讽的谴责吗？这是我们天性中较为低劣的一部分，在缺乏其他已经消失了几十年的发泄方式的情况下，语法允许我们通过这种方式将其宣泄出来。
For a lot of us. One of the ultimate messages I took from your work is that we can choose to have languages that are alive or languages that are dead. And dead languages never change. And some of us might prefer those, but if you prefer life, the unpredictability of life, then living languages in many ways are much more fun. Language is a parade, and nobody sits at a parade,
对我们很多人来说。我从你的作品中得到的终极信息之一是，我们可以选择拥有活着的语言或死去的语言。死去的语言永远不会改变。我们中的一些人可能更喜欢那些，但如果你更喜欢生命、生命不可预测的特性，那么在许多方面，活着的语言要有趣得多。语言是一场游行，没有人会坐在游行队伍里，
wishing that everybody would stand still. If the language stayed the way it was, it would be like a pressed flower in a book or as I say, I think it would be like some inflatable doll rather than a person. I think that it's better to think of language as a parade that either you're watching or frankly that you're in, especially because the people are never going to stand still. It's never happened, it's never going to, and if you can enjoy it as a parade instead of wondering why people keep walking instead of just sitting on chairs and blowing on their
希望所有人都站着别动。如果语言保持原样，它就会像书本里压扁的花朵，或者正如我所说，我觉得它会像一个充气娃娃而不是一个人。我认为最好把语言想象成一场游行，要么你在观看，坦率地说，要么你身处其中，主要是因为人们永远不会停下脚步。这从未发生过，也永远不会发生；如果你能把它当成一场游行来享受，而不是去纳闷为什么人们一直在走动，而不是仅仅坐在椅子上、吹着大号却一动不动，那么你会觉得更有趣。
tubas and not moving, then you have more fun. I want everybody to have the fun I'm having. John McQuatter, thank you so much for joining me on Hidden Brain today. Thank you for having me, Sokra. This episode of Hidden Brain was produced by Raina Cohen, Maggie Penman and Thomas Liu, with help from René Clar, Jenny Schmidt, Pat Shah and Chloe Conley. Our team includes Laura Correll, Camilla Vargas Restrepo and supervising producer Tara Boyle. Special thanks to Adam Cole, who wrote and performed our rendition of the Hoki-Poki. I'm Shankar Vedantam, see you next week.
我希望每个人都能体验到我所感受到的这种乐趣。约翰·麦克沃特，非常感谢你今天来到《隐藏的大脑》。谢谢你邀请我，尚卡尔。本期《隐藏的大脑》由蕾娜·科恩（Raina Cohen）、玛吉·彭曼（Maggie Penman）和托马斯·刘（Thomas Liu）制作，雷内·克拉尔（René Clar）、珍妮·施密特（Jenny Schmidt）、帕特·沙阿（Pat Shah）和克洛伊·康利（Chloe Conley）提供了帮助。我们的团队包括劳拉·科雷尔（Laura Correll）、卡米拉·瓦尔加斯·雷斯特雷波（Camilla Vargas Restrepo）和负责监督的制作人塔拉·博伊尔（Tara Boyle）。特别感谢亚当·科尔（Adam Cole），他编写并表演了我们版本的“Hoki-Poki”。我是尚卡尔·韦丹坦，下周见。
you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
本期节目还没有评论。点击转录文本中的任何句子即可发表评论。